معنا وما زلنا مع هذه الصور الحيه
والمباشره من الخرطوم حيث الجيش السوداني
ودعم السريع يتبادلان الاطلاق النار
والاشتباكات منذ الصباح وحتى يعني منذ
خمسه ايام ولكن كان من المفترض ان يكون
هناك هدنه تم الاتفاق عليها ل 24 ساعه
للاسف هذه الهدنه لم تبدا اصلا ولم تصمد
حتى اقل من ساعه
وبالتالي طبعا ازدادت وتيره القصف
والاشتباكات هذا الصباح كان هناك استهداف
لمطار
الخرطوم حيث تمنى استهداف او
اشتعلت النيران في احد خزانات الوقود داخل
المطار ايضا في ذات الوقت كان هناك
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور حول مقر قياده الجيش
في الخرطوم
وايضا رصدنا اشتعال وارتفاع اعمده الدخان
من احد المباني في محيط هذا المقر
ايضا مشاهدينا اظهرت الصور تحليق مقاتلات
تابعه للجيش السوداني في انحاء السودان
لملاحقه تمركزات قوات الدعم السريع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات